Rory what was it like working with Tiger
and Jimmy Fallon on this campaign it was
awesome it was a lot of fun I think you
saw it there that you know we all had a
lot of fun together and interacted well
and you know I think it's it's nice to
have that sort of fun element thrown in
with Jimmy and then everyone had a good
laugh so it was good what kind of
respect that you have for Tiger in
general a lot of respect you know what
he's done
not just with his golf game but also
just for the game of golf you know as
players officer wouldn't be playing you
know for the prize funds that we are and
you know golf wouldn't be maybe wouldn't
be as mainstream as it is Tiger and what
he's done for the game so you know have
a lot of respect for him and no doubt
that he'll come back next year year so
far yeah the year is is obviously B has
been great you have two major wins you
know a couple other ones thrown in there
as well you know it's been a great
summer ie
I never visited envisioned having four
majors this early in my career so it's a
it's been a great journey I'm a really
enjoyable year there's still a lot of
golf left to play obviously but uh you
know it's it's it's been fun and
hopefully I can I can keep winning you
know as the season goes along row there
is so much pressure on the sport to
produce another star another Tiger how
acutely do you feel that I don't think I
don't need another Tiger it definitely
needs a few guys that are winning you
know are competing in majors all the
time and you know dominance in some way
and I
you know I'd love to be that guy if
that's what I'm you know the ruled I'm
trying to play right now but yeah I
don't think and he's not you know
there's only gonna be one Tiger Woods
the other that's that's for sure but I'm
trying to develop into my own sort of
role in this game and you know I'm happy
with that have you thought about what's
after this week a chance to win four
consecutive tournaments here at the
Barclays a chance to do something that
you know has it been done a long time
yeah I I know exactly you know where I
stand and you know it's been three
incredible weeks for me with the Open
Championship and a World Golf
Championship at the Bridgestone and then
the PGA so you know I'm going for four
in a row and hopefully I can I can just
keep this run go and I'd love to make it
four and I obviously had to Boston next
week and I'm trying to make it five but
you know I'll concentrate this week at
Ridgewood and at the Barclays and see if
I can get the job done there don't see
it on the Ryder Cup
yeah Ryder Cup it's gonna be it's gonna
be interesting you know the the
Americans are you know it hasn't been a
great summer for them in terms of
injuries and you know people not you
know you know I think Phil Mickelson
playing well at the PGA is a big fuss
for the American team but as a European
I definitely don't think we we can
underestimate them because you know
they're it's going to be a strong team
no matter
right there and over it tingles in March
play you know anything can happen so I
still predict it to be a pretty tight
rider come will it be strange not to see
Tiger there it will be yeah you know
each of the two Ryder Cups that I've
played he's been a part of them there's
no doubt that you know a healthy Tiger
Woods would be a you know I agree in
addition to the American team but um you
know they're definitely gonna miss him
but it doesn't mean that you know other
players are you know come step up and
take his place well it it may feel a bit
premature but can we look ahead to the
spring and the master is winning that
tournament would mean so much to you it
would mean so much to Nike will you do
anything different to improve your
chances of winning I don't think so I
mean the Masters has always been one of
my favorite tournaments of the year I
feel like I've played well there before
and I'm just not quite got the job done
it seems like it's always been sort of a
nine-hole stretch which is you killed my
chances there so I don't think I'll do
anything different I might go and play a
couple of practice rounds with a couple
of the members that I've gotten to know
and maybe they can you know give me a
couple little tips here and there but
not time off or anything like that
no no time off no I mean just I'll play
my usual stretch you know leading up to
the gust and make sure that I'm
well-rested I'm not going to overplay
going into the masters but you'll make
sure that I'm not rusty either Rory you
can't reams of that 3-wood number 10
from 281 yards out how it defines your
PGA Championship I don't have dreams
because it definitely wasn't one of my
better shots of the week oh it was a
lucky shot you know it wasn't the shot
that I was intending to hit but
obviously it worked out really well and
you know delighted that that it rolled
up to where it did I was able to make
Eagle I'm not really that kick-started
the back nine for me because I was
really flat and I really needed
something to get me going and you know
not 3-wood sort of changed everything
because in this sport really done it's
hard to keep young people involved these
days what do you think is the way to do
that I think there's a few you know I
there's a few grid you know and they
should have like they're to get to get
young golfers involved in the game you
know I've involved with the PGA of
America and their junior golf league to
you know get youngsters into the game
and sort of make it more of a team sport
you know so they interact with kids and
they don't feel like they're getting
left live so that's been a you know
that's been really positive but uh I
mean I think having you know younger
kids having role models like you the
younger guys like Rickie Fowler myself
you know jordan Spieth these sort of
guys you can only be good for the game
as well
okay